pim en position difficile pour le
président que vous êtes du groupe
lr aujourd'hui vis-à-vis des manuels
macro où tout est clarifié dans les
choses sont très claires je pense que le
revers que en marche a enregistré pour
les sénatoriales nous donne une mission
une double mission
il faut que le soldat incarne un
équilibre en termes de pouvoir c'est à
dire qu emmanuel macron ne peut pas
prétendre mettre main basse sur toutes
les institutions de la république
donc nous seront garants d'un équilibre
des pouvoirs avec une opposition qui
sera une opposition exigeante et
intelligente on améliorera les choses
mais quand c'est pas bon pour les
français nous le diront et puis nous
sommes la voix des territoires et je
pense que l'exécutif a eu beaucoup de
maladresse vis-à-vis notamment des élus
locaux pas seulement financières en
termes de considération quand on dit que
les locaux servent à rien qui en a
beaucoup trop alors que 90% vous le
savez très bien sont bénévoles
alors que finalement tout ce qui n'est
pas résolu par paris leur tombe sur les
bras il faut avoir un peu de
considération envers ceux qui se
dévouent pour la république entendu le
mot respect il reçoit de la part du
président du sénat est ce que vous
diriez que emmanuel macron a manqué de
respect il a menti en tout cas de
considération quand on dit ya trop
d'élus locaux ça veut dire qu'ils sont
inutiles alors vous savez moi j'ai fait
campagne
j'ai vu beaucoup d'élus locaux et ils
sont au bord du découragement beaucoup
nous ont dit écoutez nous on va déposer
le paquetage parce que c'est tellement
difficile
si en plus on nous manque de
considération alors à quoi sert ton je
pense que la france a besoin de plus de
civisme
or les élus locaux qui sont encore une
fois ceux qui se dévouent pour les
autres représentent ce civisme et on n'a
pas besoin de moins de civisme questions
sur les institutions on entendait
françois noël buffet qui nous disait que
la porte était ouverte sauf sur un point
un point clé est ce que vous confirmez
que la porte est ouverte
je confirme que on a toujours une porte
ouverte ici mais qu' il y aura pas non
plus de chèque en blanc
voilà et quand je dis que nous serons et
que nous sommes une opposition
intelligente exigeante
il n'est pas question d'avaliser
n'importe quoi qu par exemple
déshabillerait les territoires qui sont
les plus pauvres en démographie la
france périphérique existe il y à une
france au delà du périphérique parisien
par conséquent il faut en tenir compte